hey what's going on everybody welcome
back to the cosmic wonder where we talk
all things marvel and mc when she-hulk
episode 2 is now out i apologize for not
having a watch party for it last night i
had some family stuff to deal with that
i'm still currently dealing with so this
breakdown will be a little shorter than
normal but we'll be back at it with the
watch parties next week now she-hulk
episode 2 is pretty straightforward
however there are some pretty major
easter eggs that we need to talk about
of course we have the big hulk easter
egg basically confirming that we are
indeed going to be getting a hulk solo
film probably world war hulk which we'll
talk about and we have a wolverine
easter egg it does kind of seem like
they have confirmed that wolverine does
exist in the mcu now marvel studios has
already confirmed that mutants are now
in the mcu they did that with miss
marvel kamala khan being the first
mentioned mutant of the mcu however
don't let this confuse you because in
miss marvel they clearly stated that
it's her genetics that make her
different it's her genetics that make
her a mutant the x gene so just because
miss marvel was the first mutant
introduced to us in the mcu does not
mean that she is the first mutant period
in the mcu in fact some deleted concept
art from miss marvel shows a cosplayer
dressing up as cyclops as an x-men not
just cyclops himself but cyclops who is
a member of the x-men because he wore
the x symbol on his chest so if that
concept art tells us anything it tells
us that the x-men are probably already a
team inside of the mcu however i don't
think wolverine is a part of that team
yet let's dive right into the wolverine
easter egg so in this episode we
obviously see the aftermath of jyn
turning into she-hulk in the courtroom
now ultimately jen saves everybody in
the courtroom specifically the jury from
titania this leads to her boss meeting
her in the bar and basically tells her
that the judges and the jury were biased
towards her because they saved her life
and she's a superhero and this is a huge
liability for the firm so they have to
let her go and when her boss entered she
was in she-hulk form so she wasn't drunk
but he asks her to go back to jennifer
walters form in which she does but then
immediately becomes very drunk so she
kind of doesn't follow everything but
when he says that she's fired she snaps
into it and realizes what he's saying
now after this a little bit of time goes
by and we can see jen walters applying
for different jobs at law firms if you
notice the background of each firm she
starts off at a really nice really fancy
law firm probably a pretty big one but
as we see her take more and more
interviews you can actually see the
quality of the firm and the office
degrade it starts off with really nice
offices and goes down gradually to a
really bad office showing us that she
can't even get a job at a really bad law
firm so she ends up searching for jobs
and we can see her looking for these
jobs on her laptop in which there's a
huge easter egg for wolverine there's
also an easter egg for iron man we can
see that there's an advertisement for
iron man 3s and these are basically
modeled off of air jordans and it is a
very tony stark fang to have his own
sneaker line now since they're iron man
3s tony stark himself might have
actually started the sneaker line when
he was alive starting of course with the
iron man 1 or maybe even called it the
iron man mach 1 just like his first suit
also to the left of that there's a
barcode marvel seems to be putting these
barcodes in each disney plus episode
that they have if you scan that you can
get a free digital she-hulk comic but
here's where the huge easter egg for
wolverine comes in below the iron man
3's we can see related articles and one
of them says man fights with metal claws
in bar bra now it's really hard to
believe that this could be an easter egg
for anything else besides wolverine
metal claws and barbra the metal claws
have to be referring to wolverine's
adamentium claws and let's face it we
know wolverine likes to get into bar
brawls this means that wolverine might
already exist in the mcu and like i
mentioned before about the x-men easter
egg it looks like the x-men and a bunch
of other mutants probably already exist
in the mcu as well now based off of the
concept art showing us cyclops and his
x-men uniform that probably means the
x-men team is established however since
they don't know who wolverine is and
simply say a man with claws that means
that wolverine has most likely not been
recruited for the x-men yet otherwise he
would probably be known so the article
would state wolverine gets into a bar
brawl not man with metal claws
regardless of whether or not he is with
the x-men or has been contacted by
professor xavier or any other x-men yet
this is still a very huge confirmation
that wolverine does exist in the mcu
right now the mutants are in the mcu and
hopefully we'll get some sort of an
announcement of when to expect the
mutants at disney's d23 expo that is
coming next month now below this you can
also find an easter egg for the eternals
there's another article with the
headline why there is a giant statue of
a man sticking out of the ocean this is
a direct reference to the end of the
eternals where tayamat is essentially
being born and coming out of the ocean
now sarzi managed to stop him by
transforming his matter into stone
essentially but he was sort of just left
there and the eternals were then taken
away so really i don't think the humans
have any type of explanation as to how
that got there so right now they're
actually calling it a stone statue and
don't realize that it's actually a
celestial a dead celestial but a
celestial now of course i would say the
second biggest easter egg because the
wolverine easter egg would be the
biggest one is that hulk is returning to
sakar jyn gets an offer for a new law
firm that wants her to lead a super
division of the law firm and this is
exactly what happens in the comics
however her first client would be emil
blonsky aka the abomination and this is
obviously kind of a conflict of interest
with her considering how he tried to
kill her cousin now obviously jen wants
to be a lawyer again and although this
is not an ideal situation for her she
wants to take the opportunity but
doesn't want to really make her cousin
bree spanner mad so she calls him up and
tells him the situation pretty much
already having made up her mind that she
is going to accept the job and is going
to represent emil blonsky but hulk says
he's okay with it and that emil actually
wrote him a nice little poem so all is
forgiven but we learned that the hulk is
heading towards the car now if you've
been following the channel the past few
weeks you know that we've been talking a
lot about the hulk's future solo movie
very heavily rumored to be a world war
hulk storyline and it looks like this is
actually going to center somewhat around
the hulk's son scar which is probably
who he is visiting and the one who most
likely sent him the message now in the
comics in planet hulk in the world war
hulk storyline the illuminati basically
determine on their own that the hulk is
too dangerous to keep on the planet so
they trick him and send him into space
he eventually lands on the planets of
car and he becomes a gladiator he
ultimately starts a revolution like korg
did but is successful and eventually
rules over sakhar he finds himself a
wife she gets pregnant but then the ship
that the illuminati sent him there on
explodes killing his wife and his unborn
child now from there the hulk is super
pissed so he decides to return to earth
to get revenge he first stops at the
moon defeats black bolt then goes to
earth and defeats pretty much all of the
superheroes the hulk gets so enraged and
he gets so mad that even a step from the
hulk is starting to break the earth so
he tells tony stark to use a machine on
him to stop him from becoming the hulk
and stop him from destroying the earth
now eventually the hulk goes on to find
out that his son actually is alive
however in the comics at least his son
kind of sucks and he wants to kill him
however he is a hulk and he is
incredibly strong and this is probably
at least somewhat of the story that
we're going to see in the hulk solo film
based off of the rumors that we've heard
so far it is kind of going to be like
another civil war story in the mcu with
sides having to be taken now we don't
know if the avengers are going to get
involved but the battle will most likely
be between the hulk and his son or if
the hulk's son is killed in this we
could actually see the hulk turn into
the actual hulk the extremely rageful
monster that cannot be stopped i'm
hoping that happens whether or not his
son dies i'm hoping something happens to
make the hulk just insanely rageful and
we get a true hulk in the mcu again not
a smart hulk so she-hulk episode 2
ultimately ends with jennifer walters
taking the case of emil blonsky however
the media releases a video of a meal
abomination fighting wong in an
underground tournament which we saw in
shanghai and the legend of the tin rings
so this is what she is going to have to
deal with next episode trying to prove
that her client is innocent while also
at the same time there is proof out
there that he escaped his prison cell
however since we've seen many of the
trailers and i've seen wong in jennifer
walters office and in the prison cell
sitting at a desk with the microphone it
does seem like wang is going to at least
attempt to help jennifer out but we'll
figure that out in the next episode in
the meantime let me know what you think
about these two insanely huge easter
eggs in she-hulk episode 2. let me know
your thoughts down below about wolverine
and world war hulk please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on all the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
you